President Trump has said that Russia
needs to get out of Venezuela warning
all US options are on the table the
threat comes after around a hundred
Russian troops touch stand in Caracas on
Saturday a move called an unnecessary
provocation by Washington oh just so you
understand all options are offered
Moscow has already responded to Trump's
threat by offering the u.s. to take the
lead and take its troops out of Syria
I'll discuss the story with RT Ziggy's
done off well the u.s. is very touchy
when it comes to Venezuela who could
have thought right so here's what
happened and what sent Washington
basically full agro over the weekend
Russia had sent about a hundred of its
military personnel over to Caracas and
this is exactly what triggered
Washington this is exactly what
triggered the United States they called
it a provocation now you have Trump
saying that Russia should get out of
Venezuela right now here's what net
trumps National Security Advisor John
Bolton had to say in regards of this
have a listen United States will not
tolerate hostile foreign military powers
meddling with the western hemispheres
shared goals of democracy security and
the rule of law the Venezuelan military
must stand with the people of Venezuela
so really you can see how Washington
really views Venezuela is its own
backyard aware it's free to do whatever
it wants really so for instance when
Washington cherry picks a president it
likes for Venezuela forget the elections
it's fine when Russia sends its military
personnel there advises for instance
that's a big no-no I'm sorry I don't
want to laugh it's just the only that
did seem pretty thick United States
won't tolerate foreign military powers
meddling let's move it on though what's
Moscow officially had to say about this
she's been saying that nothing out of
the ordinary really is happening here
it's been pointing to the fact that
Moscow and Carrick
as an agreement struck all the way back
in 2001 that allows Moscow to send a
small contingent not of its combat
troops but military advisers to the
country to Venezuela and in fact there
are well there are good reasons for that
I should say because Venezuela has
historically been a major customer of
Russia's weapons of Russia made weapons
many of them are very elaborate and it
is difficult to use them so that's why
military advisors why that's why it's
natural for them to come to the country
and teach the Venezuelan military the
ropes of how to operate these complex
systems like the s-300 for instance
anti-missile defense systems now when it
comes to the crisis in Venezuela as a
whole Moscow is maintaining that it has
been acting in strict accordance with
international law in fact it says that
its position is one of the key factors
why Washington hasn't intervened in
Venezuela more than it already has done
also it has said that Washington's
position on this has basically denied
Latin American countries its sovereignty
have a lesson the u.s. has once again
decided to bring order to Latin America
starting with Venezuela we regret that
the Organization of American States has
aided Washington in straightening its
colonial habits as if unaware that any
other country in the region can entering
full on the u.s. pressure and I mean any
other country in this sense I mean it's
not an empty not a threat but not an
empty warning in this sense because
previously Washington had already teased
that it has Cuba and Nicaragua on its
regime-change less so but I mean this
good ground for that too
let's go commentator and journalist John
White says that Russian troops in
Venezuela sends a powerful message to
Washington this is just further evidence
of an empire that's entered as Mad Dog
Peace in the same week as a trump
administration illegally recognized the
legally occupied city in Golan Heights
is is really sovereign territory nervous
issuing diktats against Russia for
dealing too
in accordance with our treaty that it
has signed with the existing government
of Venezuela the legitimate government
of Venezuela twice elected president
Nicolas Maduro under the country's
existing Constitution even though
there's only 100 Russian troops or
military advisors in Venezuela just
arriving weekend there symbolically it
sends a very powerful message because
this is a new development in queer and
multipolarity is a new game in town
multipolarity exists whether Washington
links to accept it or not and the fact
that these military advisers are
operating in conjunction with an ally in
America which the US has long considered
its backyard and we know that the u.s.
especially the Trump administration
believes that Venezuela is a wholly
owned subsidiary of Washington then
again it sends a very powerful message
it's a very strong message and I think
Washington is very worried about the
symbolism of these Russian advisers
arriving in Venezuela more than they are
about what size the forces or its
capability
you